[Music]
developing faster on kubernetes we're
gonna show you how to use Google
container tools in cloud build so let's
get started so I'm David Garrow I'm a
developer advocate based out of Paris
France and I love everything that's
related to developer experience and I
love cats and there's no connection
between the two and you can reach me on
Twitter and github hey everyone my name
is Priya Wadhwa I'm a software engineer
and GCP I work on a bunch of different
open-source tools like scaffold can echo
and mini cube and that's my github and
Twitter if anyone's interested okay so
let's talk about what it's like to be a
developer in kubernetes working on
kubernetes who here already develops on
kubernetes raise your hands and who is
interested in developing on kubernetes
okay cool we're gonna talk more about
about what that's like and making your
workflows a bit faster do you like it
being a developer in the community as
well okay because this is our opinion
yeah our opinion is that yeah yeah it's
kubernetes is really cool and you can
deploy some awesome applications but
sometimes the process of developing on
kubernetes can be time-consuming and
difficult so we're going to talk about
making it a bit easier so let's talk
about what a typical workflow deploying
to kubernetes might look like so I have
this really simple go application which
just prints out hello world every second
so I'm gonna I want to deploy this
application to kubernetes and I'm gonna
start by making sure that it works as I
expect with a simple go run so it looks
pretty good and at this point I need to
containerize my go application so that I
can deploy to kubernetes lis later so I
have this docker file and I'm gonna
build my container with a docker build
cool and at this point I would normally
push my image but I'm using a local
cluster so I don't have to and to deploy
this container to communities I
have this pod spec and I can deploy to
Cooper news with the coop control apply
command so we've we have our pod created
we can take a look at our logs and they
look pretty good it's what I expect yeah
it's deployed but what if I want to make
a change to my application I want to say
something else so the first thing that I
need to do is go back into my main dot
go file and make my change so maybe you
want to stay hello next instead so I
need to rebuild my image now but this
time I'm going to tag with a v2 tag so
that we can version control our
containers and and then I would push my
image and the next thing I need to do is
patch my mo file that's a super
interesting job right fetching young
flies and then apply my new PI and that
yellow speck and we check the logs it
looks pretty good so that's a lot of
commands yeah that was a lot of commands
and basically this whole process is what
me and David call the infinite loop of
pain and suffering even the smallest
code change requires a ton of commands
in my terminal I have to rebuild my
image remember to tag it differently
push my image patch Miami with the new
tag run a coup control apply and then
verify that the changes I made are
actually what I wanted to see and any
error at any point in the cycle can
result in me having to go back and debug
and spend a lot of time trying to fix
whatever I whatever I went wrong so
people often solve this issue with bash
scripts and make files and they'll
automate parts of this cycle away but is
there an even easier way I hope there is
okay so the first the first tool we're
going to talk about is scaffold scaffold
is a CLI open-source tool that you can
find on github under the Google
container tools organization and you can
just download it and get sorry and it
gives you
he achieved development for Cuban ideas
whether you're working with a local or
remote cluster it works on any cloud
provider any instance of Cuban ideas and
I said it's open source so how do you
scaffold so I'm sorry to tell you that
before you can use careful you have to
write more yellow files
are you okay with that because if you
don't like yeah more files
don't touch Cuban that's okay but
scuffle makes it easy for us to not
write this this llamó file we have a
comment call scuffle you need that we
try to introspect my sources and we'll
find the daka files and the Yamal
manifest and we try to match them so
that I've got a scaffold document
pre-generated for me
so at least one out of fact it is the
yellow file that Priya showed you I'm
gonna say yeah I think it's the right
configuration so now that I have this
configuration with my sources I can do
nice command such as not that such as
scaffold scaffold build not really
interesting it's just doing part of the
cycle that Priya showed you it's going
to build your images this time there's
only one image it's going to tag it
that's interesting because you don't
have to think about the tag remember
when pre are switched we want from v1 to
v2 because she knew she changed
something scuffle will do it for you
based on get get tags but you can do
something more interesting you can do
scuffle run scuffle run will build you
image will tag you images will take the
tag put them in the Yamal and send it to
Q&A test which is quite nice but you can
also do scuffle run - - tail and this
time it does the whole cycle in one
command it will show you the logs of all
the containers that were built and
deployed by scaffold so this is the full
cycle that Priya show you is only one
command awesome wants to try scaffold
already a few people okay we're gonna
try to have more because you're
developers you told us you were
developers so we're gonna do
scaffold eV which is just for you it's
exactly the same but it will also watch
for five changes so that when you fight
you change something in any of your
artifacts it will rebuild that image and
redeploy what needs to be
let me show that to you I'm gonna put a
new tab and i'm gonna change my my code
okay
typo double typo I'm going to save it
and boom scaffold detects that rebuild
my image retag change the mo redeploy
gives me the updated logs okay so to sum
up you just concentrate on your code you
don't have to think about that whole
cycle all the commands you can forget
about them just learn one command
scaffold dev so who wants to try
scaffold on Monday when they're back to
the to work okay
yeah bit more okay cool but there's one
problem we showed you that you changed
something and it's very quick to rebuild
but you real life building a docker
image doesn't take two seconds right who
has Daka be aesthetic more than 10
seconds or 30 seconds oh okay
it can be very very long I took a Java
example here to show you the problem if
you don't know it so who's the Java
developer here okay same problem applies
to Python on node or whatever it's
always faster to build your applications
locally on your machine than with docker
containers so here's the java
application so usually to build it you
would run such command because it was
built already on my machine it takes
only a few seconds to build I can bill
it two times takes two seconds okay now
I've got a docker file I want to
continue eyes my application so I've got
a doc if I which is already quite
complicated to write there's quite a few
tricks in that doctor file to make it to
make it nice with you and I'm gonna I'm
gonna build I'm gonna build my
application it's going to be very quick
because I built it already on my machine
but now I'm gonna change something in
the code I'm gonna change a comment oops
what am I
changed just a comment here okay how
long do you think it will take to
rebuild the docker image 10 seconds 1
minute 2 minutes 4 minutes ok the thing
is is that it's going to redownload all
the dependencies from my project all the
plugins ok so it's gonna take maybe four
minutes on a slow connection and it's
going to be more than that on very slow
connection so this is the problem with
docker builds it has a smart caching
mechanism but it will never be as quick
as what you have on your machine because
here I change something in the pom llamó
it has no impact on what's on my
artifact on my built artifact but it
doesn't impact on docker caching so it
has to redownload all the plugins which
is really not nice just that for a hello
world application so we're going to show
you a second open-source tool called jip
jip stands for java image builder it's
open source you can also find it on
github same org google container tools
it's a maven and Gradle plug-in and that
you can use to build docker images
without even installing docker without
writing a docker file without learning
the docker file syntax and it gives you
fast incremental builds so I think the
Java developers in the room will really
like it all you have to do is add a new
plug-in to your Java configuration just
that you select this Jeep plug-in it's
the same application ok and now I'm
going to run a slightly different
command I'm gonna do a maven compile zip
build and give it the name of the image
that it should produce and with that
command it will be in my application and
when it's done it's going to produce the
docker image and push it in for seconds
I can change the comments in the Yamal
if you want and rebuild it should also
be about 4 seconds because everything
was already built on my machine it's
using the cache that's on my machine
it's not using the local cache so maybe
you think that's not very important but
when you
using scaffold eV and you change
something and you focus on your code you
don't want the rebuild to take a few
minutes you want it to be as quick as
possible Jeep is one solution there's
all the solutions that we won't talk
about but just know that there are
people who try to make it very quick for
you so that you can focus on your code
one last thing only to you to to to to
say is that scaffold and jib is not just
for hello worlds it works very well with
the hello world sample but here we have
a much bigger project it's a multi micro
services application based on 6 micro
services one of each of them has a
docker image and when each of them is in
a separate directory and we have more
yeah more manifest yeah yeah what we
want to deploy ok and because I've got
this cap on yeah mole I can run scaffold
eV and it's going to rebuild all my
images it's going to tag them it's going
to put all the tags in the llaman files
deploy everything showed me the logs for
all the container containers at once see
it's deployed and I can see the logs
that's nice right so it's not just for
hello world and if I change something
because I'm in dev mode like for example
I will change some java application some
Java code I'm going to change the title
here it's the Google cloud quiz for next
19 save it and boom scalpel will detect
that wilt a run zip build and really
really ploy this application for me so
it deployed only what's needed and boom
my application is is there I have a very
quick feedback and if I change something
like a static web page it can be even
faster I'm gonna add some exclamation
marks because I like them
boom it's already deployed ok let me do
that for you again because it was too
quick ok save boom scaffold sync to
define from my machine to the running
pod on a remote cluster I don't even
have to rebuild the images so it's
really
as quick as if I was working locally so
you really get the tenth 10x velocity we
scaffold so this is a schema just to
explain what scaffold data so you had
all these components the UI the turn
told again the database extra all of
them in different folders scaffold watch
the sources for all those components and
for some components it will sync the
files to the remote cluster for some
components it will run chip build to
make sure that the java application is
rebuilt on your machine and for the rest
it will do dockable
which would be a little bit slower but
still very very nice and all the ports
for all the containers are forwarded
locally on my machine so that if I
connect to remote cluster if I connect
to remote cluster well I'm going create
on gke which is a cluster with more
nodes nope okay I can run the same
scaffold F command and this time it
needs to push the images remotely but
most of them most of them were already
pushed and scaffold knows that it's got
a very smart aggressive caching
mechanism that Priya developed so it's
it's the reason why it's so quick but
some of the images are changed in front
of you so they need to be rebuilt and
pushed and when it's done I will be able
to connect to my remote cluster the same
way as I was connecting on the local
cluster it's almost there yeah so I'm
collected on localhost but in fact I'm
corrected to my remote cluster thanks to
pause for worrying and I've got the
exact same experience if I change
something here more explanation marks
yeah it's gonna be synced like
automatically is it was it yeah I think
it was no maybe not there's a bag okay
Athens that scaffold scaffold so David
just talked about using jib to make your
builds a little bit faster scaffold also
supports using basil and so you can
build
locally with docker you can build on the
cloud with Google cloud build or you can
build your images on a kubernetes
cluster with Kenna Co we also support
testing with container structure tests
and deploying your application with qu
control customize or helm so if you use
any of these tools already in your
kubernetes application development
workflow you can just keep using them as
long as you put that stuff into your
scaffold EML scalpel will be smart
enough to know to deploy or build with
those things you're already with the
tools you're already using yeah this is
very important for the scaffold team
that you keep the tools you like like
helm or customize or cube CTL and there
are integrated in scaffold so that you
can just focus on the code and it work
with any Kuban ideas cluster gke any
cloud provider on Prem local block a
desktop mini cube it's very important if
you have a hybrid set up or on Prem
setup it works very well too so it gives
us very tight feedback loop and you
should try it on Monday
like Monday ok cool
so David showed us how to use scaffold
as a CLI tool but can it be even easier
and yes again so we are one of the teams
at Google just released cloud code which
is an IDE extension that runs scaffold
for you directly from your IDE so it
basically does everything we just showed
scaffold run scaffold dev but from the
comfort of IntelliJ or vs code if you
use either of those who's using vs code
here IntelliJ okay so call the room so
let's do a quick demo so I have this
really retro game of tic-tac-toe and
it's not very colorful so let's make it
a little bit prettier so go do some GK
right yeah yeah deploy done gke so it's
pretty simple just to microservices I
have a tic-tac-toe front-end written in
JavaScript and colours micro-service
written in go and basically this file
tells tells the application what colors
I want my X's and O's to be for
tic-tac-toe
so if I want to change the colors and
make them a little bit more interesting
what's your favorite color at David I
don't know are you did that one okay so
with cloud code like so you saw I just
made some changes to my ID and with
cloud code I don't even have to leave
the IDE to deploy these changes to my
cluster so you can see that with cloud
code I can deploy I can create a new gke
cluster I can run a continuous deploy
which is basically just the scaffold dev
loop that David was just showing every
time I save a file in my IDE it'll
rebuild my image and push it to my
cluster again so for now I'm just gonna
deploy my application to my cluster and
the cool thing about cloud code is if I
have different profiles I can choose to
only deploy a certain part of my
application so I know I'll only change
the colors microservice so I'm only
going to redeploy that piece I don't
have to do it but it's nice to have
profiles to tweak your build process or
GPI process yeah we can take a look at
the scaffold animal actually and what
that looks like but I have just a simple
scaffold UML here with my two
microservices and paths to the docker
files for those images and then a
profile for my colors microservice which
will only build and deploy that pop that
bit and then one for my front end as
well and if we take a look at our cloud
code logs we basically just did a
scaffold run again except this time
directly from our IDE and we went
through the same process that we've
already been through except cloud code
is really nice and it'll tell me when my
deployment has rolled out and it's
successfully deployed so if we head back
over to our game we have some colors so
it was super easy
it didn't never had to leave my IDE and
it also told me when it was finished
which is really cool so cloud code also
has some fun other things it does
scaffold llamó validation so if i wanted
to add an artifact here say I have a
third micro-service which does something
except this one is built with basil so I
can start typing in basil and cloud code
will autofill the rest of the yellow for
me and I just have to put in my basil
target it also
so we'll do some validation so if I put
in an integer here which it doesn't
expect it'll let me know and if I hover
over different pieces with my scaffold
animal it'll tell me what those pieces
mean and what scaffold is expecting
which is just really nice
during my development process yeah cat
code gives you this validation and
documentation on scaffold yeah more but
any yeah more manifest for kubernetes or
deployments project cetera you have the
online documentation and validation
exactly so it just makes a kubernetes of
element a little bit easier because I
always have to go and look up what a pod
spec is meant to look like before I
write a new one cool yeah so with cloud
code for vs code continuous deployment
you can still run your scaffold run and
scaffold dev except this time just with
a button click from your IDE
um will manifest validation and more so
you could download that today as well
yeah and then call code for intelligence
well very similar but basically it'll
just run scaffold for you and you can
keep focusing on writing your code which
is the best part okay so we showed how
to develop locally whether it's on the
command line or using your favorite IDE
but at some point your application will
get bigger and you want to be able to
build on a cloud because building on
your machine has its limits especially
if you have lots of micro services you
don't want to build all of them in
sequence locally so we're going to talk
about one of this managed service we
have on Google cloud which is cloud
build cloud build is Funi managed CI CD
product that gives you extremely fast
build that you can use to automate your
deployments so you can build docker
images or any binaries you can run your
tests you can run your integration test
you can deploy at the end of your build
pipeline so you should really take a
look at Google be a cloud bill and we're
going to show you what you use it so
usually to use cloud build you end up
submitting a cloud bill llamó through
the comment line or through the UI
this is a typical command you would run
g-cloud builds submit and you give it a
cloud billion and this is the content of
the cloud bit llamo this is a list of
steps
that are going to run on your code so
cloud bill will clone you your repo and
will run docker images steps on your
codebase for example here this first
step will run npm install on your source
sources and then NPM NPM run tests to
make sure that the unit tests are run
and then it will do a dollar bill to
make sure to produce the docker image
and this docker image will be pushed by
cloud bill so if I run this command from
my sources it will send my sources and
run all those commands so that at the
end I've got a docker image that was not
built on my machine but built on the
cloud okay but it's even easier if
you're using scaffold I just wanted to
show you a few us but priya is going to
show it later on
so we scaffold is even easier here's my
small hexagon example with all the
artifacts and I added a small profile
just four lines and with this profile
you can just say okay if this profile is
activated you will not be locally on
your machine using docker but you will
build remotely on the cloud all the
artifacts in parallel let me show that
to you I'm gonna just switch back to
docker okay so I'm going to do scaffold
build not using this profile just to
show you that it's building locally
using docker and all the artifacts were
already built so scaffold is very quick
to tell you that and I'm gonna now
activate the cloud build profile so now
this time Skyfall should send sources to
cut build and compile all the artifacts
on the cloud but because it's smart
thanks to Priya code it's going to find
that all those images already exist
remotely some of them exist with a
different target so it's just going to
retag them it's not even going to send
sources to club builder that's nice
right so you can really beat very
quickly but I'm going to change
something I'm gonna change I don't know
you I hear exclamation marks I told you
I want explanation marks I can't build a
scaffold build with the profile this
time one of the artifact does not
this remotely in my registry so scuffle
will take the sources put them in a
table or send it to cloud build
triggered a cloud will run which will
then run some commands on top of it
basically we do a docker build and a
docker push at the ana and it would be
very quick and it's even quicker when
you have lots of artifacts to be
revealed because it's going to build
them in parallel and one incident
scaffold will tell me so you see you
don't even have to learn the cloud build
a CLI or API or UI you can use the same
tool scaffold or your cloud code
extension and you're gonna build on the
cloud which is quite nice right and you
don't have to write that cloud build
animal yeah you don't have to learn it
one less Yama file okay cause be a
scaffold so it builds all the artifacts
in parallel it has very aggressive smart
caching mechanism so that any image that
was already built and push even with a
different tag you don't have to go
through the whole build process and you
don't have to do your rough to add an
additional Yama file okay you should
really try code build it's very
efficient for that but there's also a
lots of additional use cases that you
might want to explore for example cool
so David just talked about how we can
use scaffold and cloud built together to
build our images remotely on the cloud
while doing local development but we can
also use cloud build and scaffold
together to create a continuous
deployment pipeline which will push your
application to your Akoo Burnette ease
cluster for you so let's talk about what
this would look like say you're a
developer and your code lives on github
and you want to create and you want to
add a new feature to your codebase so
the first thing you're gonna do is
develop locally hopefully what scaffold
now and get your feature of been running
and then push those changes to github
and as soon as they're merge to master
that's where our pipeline will come in
so Google cloud build will we're gonna
use a Google cloud build build trigger
to watch your repo and it'll know
whenever you've merged a new change into
your codebase and once it sees that you
have it'll pick up your new codebase and
run a scaffold run on the codebase and
that'll redeploy your new feature to
your cluster at which point you can
visualize whatever changes you made as
you normally would so this is a pipeline
configuration we have another cloud
build young mole but this is basically
what cloud build is going to run on
every code change so first the first
step is pretty simple it'll just get
credentials for the cluster that you
want to deploy your application to and
then the second step is just a scaffold
run which we've done a bunch of times
now so it'll rebuild your images push
them and then redeploy your application
for you
just want to say something that's very
important we show you you can use
careful on your machine but you can use
it on cloud build or any CICS system
because since you've listed all the
artifacts you want to build since you've
listed how you want to deploy them you
can do that from Jenkins or anywhere for
that matter so really this is what pre
I'm showing you she's gonna run scuffle
from cloud build instead of what we
shown where we ran cloud bill from
scaffold okay you can do it any way you
want whatever combination let's do a
quick demo of how this works so I'm
gonna go back to my colors and change
them again except this time let's say
we're pushing to a production
environment instead of a staging
environment so I'm gonna want to version
control and not just deploy my changes
directly from my IDE so I'm gonna commit
these changes to github
David does it look good to you code
review sorry I'm just gonna push the
master yeah I like the color so you can
push cool so now that I've pushed a
master at this point Google Cloud build
should pick up the change in my code
base and start a new build so we should
check the UI and looks like a build has
already started and it'll basically run
the two steps that I already showed in
the pipeline configuration so the first
step gets credentials from a cluster and
the second step will do a scaffold run
and I've actually set up my build
triggers so that they only run when
certain files and github are changed so
this build trigger runs only
only my colours microservice has changed
and it'll only rebuild that part of the
application just to speed up my deploy a
little bit so you were in your IDE we
just get pushed and you've got a whole C
ICD yeah Shane that is triggered it will
build all the artifacts artifacts it
will redeploy everything to the
production cluster right exactly and if
we take a look at the logs we are we've
downloaded our scaffold image and now
we're rebuilding the image you know
reality you don't have to look at the
logs right okay yeah you don't actually
it will just happen we're pushing and we
should be done soon usually this takes
around a minute and it's done so if we
head back to our application we should
see what the colors have changed so that
is a really simple example using cloud
build and scaffold together to create a
continuous deployment pipeline sometimes
it's so quick that it feels slow you
don't have to do anything you just get
push get a cup of coffee okay so a quick
recap of what we've seen so we've seen
different ways to develop faster with
kubernetes all of them are connected to
scaffold which is the tool we are
working on and that's used underneath by
cloud code so scaffold gives you a very
tight feedback loop whether you're
working locally on a local cluster or
remotely you can work on any type of
kubernetes cluster and we've seen jeep
jeep is one of the tools you can use to
build your docker images quicker and
easier more easily because you don't
have to learn the doc file syntax you
don't have to install docker it will
just use your standard build tool to
build docker images yeah cool we looked
at cloud code which lets you run
scaffold directly from your IDE so you
just have to hit some buttons and it'll
do all the work for you which is really
nice and then we also looked at cloud
build which will which can build your
images remotely on the cloud and also
help you set up a full CD pipeline for
your kubernetes application okay so
that's about it
[Music]